[Music]
lost for decades beneath the center of
naples italy the bourbon tunnel is an
underground time capsule of the city's
history
this system of tunnels and caverns was
originally conceived in the 1800s as an
escape tunnel by king ferdinand ii
connecting the royal palace to the
military barracks but the king died
before its completion
the tunnel was then abandoned until the
early 1930s when it was used as a
storage facility for impounded and
contraband vehicles
many of which are still there today
[Music]
during world war ii the tunnel changed
uses again this time becoming a military
hospital and bomb shelter
after the war it turned into a dumping
ground for rubble destroyed cars and
pro-fascist marble statues
before it was sealed
and then forgotten
it was accidentally rediscovered in 2005
when government geologists were checking
the conditions of nearby quarries
now the galleria borbonica belongs to
the public who explore the areas before
them as they wander the ancient caverns
[Music]
150 feet underground
in 30 million year old caves
an unforgettable sight glitters in the
dark
the waitomo glowworm caves in new
zealand are home to about 30 000 endemic
arachnocampa luminosa glowworms
they spend their days spinning silk
nests from the ceilings
and then lowering threads to fish for
prey much like a spider
the luminescent bead like strings are
spellbinding
the glowworms use light to attract prey
and burn off waste
the glow is created by a combination of
chemicals given off by the glowworm and
the oxygen in the air
the caves are ideal for the worms as
they need a dark damp location where
their light can be seen
[Music]
the way tomo caves they call home are
named after the maori words wei which
means water and tomo which means hole or
shaft
and although they live deep underground
the journey to see them is never one to
disappoint
[Music]
in southern central bosnia just outside
the town of konyitz and behind a quiet
unassuming building in the mountains
lies a secret place
a place designed to survive a nuclear
apocalypse
welcome
to tito's bunker
[Music]
construction of the bunker was started
by joseph brostito the president of
yugoslavia at the height of the cold war
it took 26 years to complete and was a
well kept top secret for decades
the horseshoe shaped structure goes over
600 feet deep into the mountain and is a
maze of offices conference rooms doors
as well as living quarters for tito and
his wife
in the event of a nuclear strike the
bunker could protect 350 of the most
important political and military persons
in the country
the bunker was almost destroyed in the
early 90s during the bosnian war but
went untouched remaining a time capsule
from the cold war its bedrooms bathrooms
phones and typewriters still lying ready
for atomic war
today the bunker serves a more peaceful
purpose as a modern art museum housing
one of the most important and valuable
art collections in southern europe
built for war between east and west
tito's bunker is now a safe haven for
creative works from artists from around
the world
to wander this mausoleum in shiraz iran
is like stepping into the holiest of
light shows
[Music]
which roughly translates to king of the
light in persian
is a funerary monument and mosque a
beautiful holy place for thousands of
muslim worshippers
the structure is made of multicolored
pieces of tile and glass and is
considered to be the third most
important pilgrimage site in iran
initially started around 900 a.d as a
burial site for an important shia muslim
figure
the mosque continued to be expanded and
improved
the decision to adorn the mosque with
its iconic mirror ball decoration came
from queen tashkatun in the 14th century
she wanted the mosque to intensify any
light a thousand times over an homage to
the mosque's name
although meant to be a holy shrine an
important pilgrimage location for shia
muslims people of any faith can marvel
at the mosque's immense beauty
[Music]
there's been a secret under the streets
of liverpool for hundreds of years
[Music]
a mysterious network of tunnels built
200 years ago and stretching on for
miles was built by eccentric and
successful tobacco merchant joseph
williamson
there's evidence of tunnels built and
then immediately bricked back up again
and arches that lead to nowhere
but the purpose and the reason behind
building these
is unknown
there's theories of course
one that he and his wife were part of an
apocalyptic cult and these tunnels were
to be their hideout
another that its only aim was to provide
jobs for the men in the area to combat
the high levels of unemployment
a final theory is they were used for
smuggling or other secret operations by
williamson himself
construction on the tunnels stopped
immediately after williamson's death in
may 1840
and it wasn't rediscovered until 2001.
since then a team of local retirees has
made it their mission to excavate the
tunnels
but with no records to offer explanation
the purpose of the tunnels or even a map
of how far they span
has made it a mysterious and tough job
[Music]
in this curious lagoon the rivers may
run red
but rest assured it's water
not blood
although you could be forgiven for
confusing the two
[Music]
the red lagoon is located twelve
thousand feet above sea level in an area
of chile so remote that it wasn't even
known by the national tourism office
until 2009
and maybe that's a good thing because
much like the pyramids in egypt the
lagoon is believed to be cursed
legend says that the waters are owned by
the devil himself and he is responsible
for the mysterious disappearances that
have occurred along the shores
the thermal temperatures of the water at
100 to 120 degrees stop even wild
animals from approaching it
devils aside what causes this blood red
water well biologists studying the
lagoon recently traced it to algae
growing in the depths of the lake
still
much of this lagoon remains a mystery
a visit to this place is a reminder
there is still much to marvel at on this
planet
what you're seeing was built by one man
pebble by pebble
over 33 years
[Music]
one morning mailman ferdinand chaval
stumbled across an interesting looking
stone on his delivery route
he picked it up
and from there an obsession began
using stones he collected on his walk
cheval worked each night without any
formal training to build what is now
called the palais ideal
the final structure is 85 feet long and
300 feet high
it mingles chinese algerian and northern
european influences to create a
fantastic and completely original castle
of grottoes
[Music]
he opened the palace in 1870 for the
public to enjoy
in his own words he says
you start wondering if you have not been
carried away into a fantastic dream with
boundaries beyond the scope of
imagination
and this incredible bizarre and unique
place
does look like something you could only
see in a dream
[Music]
you